remember when people couldn't stop
talking about duck dynasty's Robertson
family a few short years ago this
close-knit Louisiana clan was the talk
of reality TV but everything changed
after Phil Robertson's notorious GQ
interview in 2013 the Robertson's
managed to stay on the air following
their brush with controversy the lost a
vast portion of their audience and were
dropped from Annie in March of 2017 did
the Robertsons just disappear after that
not by a long shot so where are they now
Phil and Kay Robertson in an interview
with local news station ka noe eight
Phil and Kate Robertson said they don't
have any grand plans for the future Phil
said he's basically going to spend all
day in the woods while Kay is looking
forward to getting back to a quieter
life Phil wasn't sad to see them pack
their cameras and go I for one was
thankful there's a lot more to doing
these TV shows and most people realize
while the Robertson family patriarch
would like everyone to think he's happy
checking duck blinds all day he's
actually been pretty busy outside
Louisiana wilderness during the 2016 US
presidential election Phil became
politically active voicing his support
for Republican candidate Ted Cruz before
switching to supporting Donald Trump and
he's been quietly playing behind the
scenes and conservative politics ever
since Phil and Kay also travel around
doing speaking engagements mainly
preaching their religious beliefs and
what Phil described as quote helping our
neighbors and living a godly life
recently he's taken to Facebook to
advocate for the NRA which should
surprise exactly no one my happiness is
killing things
boom boom bow Willie and Korie Robertson
the duck commander himself Willie
Robertson also took a deep dive into
politics as the show tapered down
speaking at the Republican National
Convention in 2016 Willie attended the
2017 presidential inauguration and even
visited the White House lately he's
hinted at possible new TV projects and
discussed the expansion of the family's
West Monroe Louisiana warehouse
I'm fixing to go crazy redneck up in
here but like his dad Willie's also not
resting on his laurels he and his wife
Cory decided to reopen Willie's duck
diner a local family themed restaurant
once featured on the show along with his
partner in the restaurant
Willie was also instrumental in
organizing relief efforts for victims of
Hurricane Harvey meanwhile Korie is
parlayed her TV fame into a brand of her
own already a New York Times bestselling
author Korie released her latest book
post duck dynasty called strong and kind
raising kids of character which she
paired with her strong in-kind
collection of housewares jewelry and
accessories but there's one area where
she and Willie differ in a surprising
break from the family Corey told CNN
that she didn't share her husband's
enthusiasm about Donald Trump and stated
that her and her husband agreed to
disagree she also called on the
President to quote be a leader that
unifies that brings people together
Sadie Robertson arguably the breakout
star of the show Willie and Corey's
daughter Sadie has become a full-blown
media figure in her own right since the
final duck call starting in 2014 when
she nearly took home the Mirrorball
trophy on Dancing with the Stars
since then she's also become a
best-selling author launched clothing
lines and started an acting career just
like her mother
Sadie's taking the concept for her book
live original and turned it into a
full-blown brand which includes a blog
and a live show
Sadie views herself as a beacon of light
in an oft dark world and she's working
on a follow-up book live fearless which
she says is about her journey of finding
freedom John Luke Robertson the second
oldest child of Willie and Korie John
Luke also got a jump start on his post
dynasty career in 2014 he authored a
series of children's books called be
arrow duck commander before venturing
into nonfiction with young and beardless
the search for God purpose and a
meaningful life a memoir about camp
volleyball and anguish over things like
his girlfriend getting texts from other
guys taking a cue from his family John
Luke also seems to be building a
personal brand he's launched a blog
called young and beardless as well as
promoted the handle through his social
media accounts although a quick look at
recent posts suggest he may already have
to consider rebranding to young and
scruffy and if that doesn't work out he
clearly as a future in endorsing canned
fish
mostly collegues decide Kavi Tina
we're bumble meteor uncle sy Robertson
I'm not come back go boom Kapow but cuz
King as last season of duck dynasty was
airing uncle sy launched his A&E
spin-off series going Cyril which pitted
the quirky technophobe against the
worldwide web
I got myself show about the Internet I'm
not even sure what that is yet he's also
busy working on new music and about to
start touring with his band uncle sy and
the psychotics which is comprised of
himself his daughter-in-law Marcia
Robertson and Bridget Tatum psy must
have learned a thing or two from his
solo series because he and his bandmates
now routinely post lengthy Facebook live
posts that keep fans engaged but also
play out like a reality show and if he
just can't get enough psy they're also
selling ringtones
hey at any rate it looks like diehard
uncle sy fans are still able to get
their fill of the eccentric Vietnam vet
and for that we say god bless the
internet jack Jase and Missy Robertson
though there was already a huge internet
kerfuffle when photos of the pre-beard
Robertson clan surfaced online it
happened all over again in September
2017 when Jase Robertson lost the battle
with the buzzer for a great cause
Jase agreed to shave as part of a
fundraiser for me amou the foundation he
and his wife Missy founded which is
dedicated to raising awareness and funds
towards research treatments and causes
of cleft lip and palate
Jason Missy were moved to start the
foundation after the outpouring of
support they received when their own
daughter Mia was born with the condition
the goal for hashtag shave Jase was to
raise $100,000 after which Jase would
shave and cut his hair and record it
live though they missed their goal Jase
honored his pledge and posted the video
on Facebook via his new venture camel
flicks which Jase describes as a place
where outdoors people hunters fishermen
fisherwoman can go and share videos
think of it like YouTube only you need a
fishing license or a hunting tag to
upload a few days after duck dynasty's
final episode aired
Missy Robertson told the Daily Journal
right now are taking some time off to
rest and reevaluate what our next steps
will be I'm enjoying being able to
travel to see my sons Reed and Cole who
are currently living in Nashville and
Malibu and spending time with Mia and
all her activities Missy has yet to
strike out on a completely new venture
but she's continued her work with her
jewelry line laminin which focuses on
pieces which are quote made by women who
have come out of very difficult
situations laminin has become more than
just a jewelry retailer it's also an
outreach program all women can come
together who would like a job who need a
job and that can express their
creativity and just being a part of each
other's lives for the creation of
laminin house missy hopes to expand
across the United States and serve as a
ministry to disadvantaged women Reed
Robertson still in Nashville and
plugging away at his fledgling country
career Reed Robertson recently released
his new EP although he's still pretty
far from the
big time he told the outdoor experience
we didn't have a plan and we didn't
really have a defined sound that we were
going for we just got in the studio and
had fun and just wrote and it just kind
of happened which is really cool
Reid was married to Brighton Thompson in
October 2016 and the newlyweds have been
posting happily ever after Instagram
shots ever since JEP and Jessica
Robertson knowing a good thing when they
saw it
Annie greenlit a spin-off for JEP
Robertson and his wife Jessica before
duck dynasty ended but like every other
Robertson JEP and Jeff just one iron in
the fire which is why in addition to
operating Jess's jewelry line cavalry
the couple also launched a podcast the
JEP and gesture in March 2017 the busy
couple said the show would be even more
revealing than before and would
definitely feature regular visits from
the rest of the Robertson family so in
case you were worried yes all the charm
of the reality show is still intact
about a timeline through now go pee in
your pants and then you go solo
yep charming thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]